how are you doing in in quarantine it's
you and your two kids right yeah and my
mom my mom quarantined with us because
she lives two minutes away from us so
for the first two weeks we completely
quarantined and then she actually took a
little launch took like three weeks and
then she started joining our family do
you know just to come and have dinner
with the kids and with me
every once in a while and that's it in
other words you don't have people
cleaning your house you don't have
people coming in at all it's just you
the kids and your mom that's it yeah
which is interesting because I was like
listen if I'm gonna have to do laundry
and clean this house up then you two
little [ __ ] are gonna help out so it
became like it was like cleaning camp
but they went to cleaning camp they now
know how to hold their socks up when I
come in when they come out of the dryer
they know I have so many adorable videos
of my kids hoovering the house it's
really it's really cute and folding you
know laundry and they now can load a
dishwasher perfectly like it's this has
been a really important time in their
lives I think so they're homeschooling
has mostly been just learning chores are
you a good mother I think so I mean it's
the thing that I work the hardest that
it's the thing that I put most all of my
energy into like it's the one thing that
I don't give myself a break on No so
what does that mean do you trust that
you know you're a good mother or do you
go to a psychiatrist and get analyzed
and say am i repeating any of the
patterns that my mother screwed up are
you improving yourself in psychoanalysis
so that you will be the maximum great
mother yes I'm very very open to having
those discussions with my therapist
because I come from a lot of trauma and
you know when you're somebody who comes
from a lot of trauma we know how we
function and I don't want to ever
project any about I mean I know I will
but I want to at least try to limit that
as much as I can
because it's not fair to my children so
you know I don't want to assume that I'm
like that I [ __ ] have all the answers
I don't I need to learn maybe to shut up
I need to
I need to listen and you know I want to
be that kind of parent
you